love this guy man unbelievable and he's
here on part let me make sure I get this
right to a chance you get a chance to
attend the cheese it bowl with Pat
McAfee oh my gosh who wouldn't want to
do that I mean now the question is as
Pat McAfee joins us here in the Rich
Eisen show the cheese at Bowl was that
what you screamed out was that the
safeword you screamed out when Rich
Rodriguez came to your house when you
were having that party supposed to is
that what that was it was a team
camaraderie building my back robbery
building barbecue my band a party so it
wasn't like hey cheese at ball cheese it
Bowl that and everyone just runs that
wasn't it yes Jesus were on hand though
it's amazing there were cheese's as a
team camaraderie building barbecue but
rich rod was the only coach that didn't
come and the only member of the entire
team that comes camaraderie building
barbecue so he would have never known
that that shame on him I'm assuming he
enjoyed Jesus down the road a little bit
more okay and let's put a pin in the
cheese that talked then for the moment
you know and and head on to it so what
what do we call then what the Patriots
were or a member of the Patriots staff
was doing in Cleveland the other day
with a video camera
Pat cool we call it optically not good
rich this is optically not a good
situation
now I thought the Robin in kovitch on my
show this morning an incubus was telling
me about how Kraft productions is its
own thing and then the Truffaut
operations is its own thing
another very naive guy you know somebody
looks me right in the face and says
something with enough conviction I'm all
it so when Bill Belichick said I a
hundred percent don't knowwe something I
believed now from what I'm being told
people are really diving into these
tapes they're not just gonna be set
ablaze like you let Spygate 1.0 I
believe people are really looking at
these tapes now from what I've heard
eight minutes of filming of the
Cincinnati Bengals sideline rich not
good not good at all you get Ernie
Addams big brain with those videotapes
maybe that offense gets humming again
gets a little confidence and all of a
sudden there's a super
favored all of a sudden but I have no
idea everything's a legend and I'm happy
that they were willing to wear a
Patriots polo
while doing this if this is exactly what
they were doing because you're just
hiding in plain sight
big dog moves and I can respect you hell
out of that but clearly cheating
well apparently was also somebody in a
Boston Bruins jersey and their little
hockey sweater too that had the camera
according to some of these reports - and
that's just what makes no sense to me is
that the Patriots let's stroll into into
a press box you know it's somebody in
the cam neely gamer you know and that
makes no sense to me Pat that makes it
seem like that's that's it that's absurd
yeah let's assume if the Patriots were
gonna cheat again now granted we don't
know what happened Richmond you know nor
I have any idea but let's assume that
the smartest football coach in the
history of football alongside this guy
named Ernie Adams who everybody all the
counties the smartest human to
potentially ever exist if they were to
do something that they had been caught
up doing before they would do it in a
little different manner especially in
2019 when everybody has a camera
attached to their phone
you know maybe dress up like a like a
dog pound member a brown fan with your
phone on it maybe something like that I
just don't know how much I believe they
walked into a press box where everybody
has a camera and started recording
something they didn't know this could be
a misunderstanding this could be a
mistake or this could be damning for the
greatest dynasty in the history of
professional sports rich that McAfee
here on the Rich Eisen show so ballpark
for me which one is it you by the way
you've done you've done just do you
understand Pat how much you've grown as
a broadcaster you've done a couple of
things here that I'm very proud of if
you know mom you're just pointing out in
the last couple minutes please number
one mom went great under the radar drop
about your show that was great I mean
you know for you to say I had Rob
Minkoff itch on my show today by the way
it's the Pat McAfee show on to zone and
Westwood One 10:00 a.m. to noon eastern
every day okay that was that was I mean
that was really stealth I picked it up
that was well done number two menu
number two is you gave both sides of the
fence okay
you didn't stake out ground on either
side of the fence because either side of
the fence could possibly be the truth
there's a gray area in between but you
pointed out both things while also
making a point in a very entertaining
manner excellent
Pat I mean that's just next-level
broadcasting right there but I am gonna
have to ask you which one it is do you
think we still could Pat we we still
could based on this conversation but
let's continue our mission but yeah but
you you are you are the host of Pat
McAfee show for a reason you are getting
up more often than not now for a reason
which do you think this is well any time
I get on a college gameday set I also
know that when you're speaking about
facts yes you need to know the entire
story so for me it seems a bit
far-fetched to think that the New
England Patriots who are the cerebral
team that's what they're I mean they had
Josh McDaniels tell the coach he was
going to be their head coach got on a
plane turn the plane back around just to
screw the culture I mean this team in
the New England Patriots is a cerebral
one so to think that they would just let
two balloons walk into a press box to
potentially do what they had already
done in the past and got caught doing in
the past seems a bit far-fetched to me
but hiding in plain sight is not a bad
way to get away with something so for me
I think it's probably a misunderstanding
where craft production sent something in
there for the do your job but you can't
help but link it back to what happened
in the past so for me I think it was
nonsense but I am eager and excited to
see how this all plays out because that
asterisk next to the Patriots that
everybody outside of New England has
everybody you walk in Indianapolis who's
the team you hate the most in the NFL
New England Patriots you walk into
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania who's the
teammates with Cleveland Brown then
little New England patient's every city
people like to throw a walk to things
that shine right Taylor Swift said that
and I think she's one percent accurate
the Pacers have been at the top of the
mount for a long time so everybody hates
that team and this is add extra
ammo for the people that hate them but
for me I just don't see how they would
let this be the reason for the way about
spying on somebody especially in 2019
when you can just get like a camera the
size of a pinhole and just stand on the
other side of the field so I just
personally this seems like this is too
amateur of an operation for the Patriots
to cheat but maybe that's neat feel the
way they were trying to do it Pat McAfee
here on the Rich Eisen show is Pat
McAfee show just caught it selfish an
opportunity to be broadcast by Kraft
productions right here on the Rich Eisen
show you know they haven't they have a
very large production come they really
do I mean from what you were told by
Nick ovitch it's true the Patriots were
way ahead of any other team by creating
their own production unit and they have
their own studio they have everything
there and as a matter of fact when we
did our show I think was in year one
Chris was that one year one when we did
our show from a Thursday night game in
New England they pitched in
they helped I mean and they had all the
cameras and all the video equipment and
everything Pat that's a fact
well they didn't have all the video
equipment because some of it got burned
you know the last not only on the field
but off the field I think they're
building up an entire world up there in
Foxborough to the crap so everything so
we can get all the monies from everybody
that goes in there that's right and you
could see as somebody who now has
ventured into much larger companies I'm
a small business myself but we partnered
with much larger company yes you can see
how things can fall through the cracks
and communication purposes and you can
see how a buffoon wouldn't know the
rules and what he was doing which I
think potentially did happen here but
but who knows because it is the patriot
so up the Jets Pat McAfee here and the
Richards Joan Jett say that they are not
going to discipline levy on bail for
bowling apparently the night that he was
ruled out with the flu before a game
against the Dolphins what happens in a
locker room when something like that
happens
Pat Mac locker room I mean that that
locker room is a wasteland anyways I
mean they had a guy who ate mono for
four weeks they have they have no have
no idea what's going on in that locker
room and for me I think society's
punish levy on bail if you have a flu
the last thing you should be doing is
fingering bones and other people are
gonna be fingering which I mean this is
not something you're offended by on a
hygiene basis not a football team eight
basis they start sniffling the wrong way
i quarantined myself in the bedroom away
from her I don't need this guy who took
a year off to rap in Miami who's one of
the most elusive and incredible running
backs of our generation we are spread
all over the damn place I'm in New York
in New Jersey once a week because of my
appearances on get up and stuff like
that where I just can't be bowling with
the fear that I'm gonna pick up the web
Bell flu that's my bigger problem than
anything but inside of the locker room
wherever you see the guy that's missing
a game that you need that I paid a lot
of money now he's not kind of messing
around it's just it's more of the same
you understand that that locker room is
in shambles you're kind of upset about
it you would expect more out of a guy
and I do you think optically just like
this video camera thing was crap
productions it just looks bad it's just
a bad move and hopefully levy on bail
ones weren't on this moving forward
because he's gonna be a vital piece of
that terrible payment they're ever gonna
be good
Pat McAfee here on the Rich Eisen show a
few more minutes left before you start
talking about cheez-its
so your Super Bowl prediction preseason
and now currently with three weeks ago
is and was what well I picked the Colts
to win the Super Bowl and then Andrew
Luck retired via Adam Schefter tweet Oh
God that kind of got tossed up that kind
of got tossed in the trash can I
personally as the season have has gone
on I feel like him too the Green Bay
Packers because Aaron Rodgers came on my
show 10 to noon every single date night
time and told me a lot of things about
that team in the way Lafleur was kind of
shaping that offense with Aaron Jones
getting well but it seems like they've
kind of fell into a rut where they might
have peeked a few weeks ago so I don't
love that this Niners team which has
come out of nowhere last year a lot of
Heights
then Jimmy G zigged instead of zagged
there's his knee up they lose nobody
know anything about him they've really
taken the world by storm it's not only
just defense but this past weekend they
showed that that offense can get going
as well and then Russell Wilson who I've
never heard
human be mites up and be as positive as
that guys I don't know how he does it
every interview is super positive on the
field he's like hey here we go here we
go here we go sounds like he's in a
dugout almost the entire time I don't
know how you can rule them out I think
the NFC is something that's going to be
captivating whatever it gets to playoff
time aside from the entities which
absolutely stinks but in the AFC that
Lamar Jackson offense I don't know how
many people predicted it would be as
incredible as it is plus you bring in
Marcus Peters which is really lit a fire
for that defense but Justin Tucker Sam
Cooke and Morgan Cox that seems like the
most complete complete team that can
compete in any fashion they can win
games in a slugfest they can win I'm
going to shoot out I like the Ravens
right now they're at the top of the
mountain my mountain to go forward but
in the NFC I'm excited to see it kind of
how it all pans out have we seen the
last of in eteri has he made his last
kick in the NFL do you think hey hey I
don't think so buddy I don't know I've
not talked to him okay because now
everybody knows I don't have children
I'm just gonna let things fly I've
agreed to the FCC's rules here just
strictly so I can make more money than
lose money but I don't really have a
filter so I've kind of put myself in a
position where I don't want to ask
military for pertinent information
because I very much know that every time
I'm on a microphone on ESPN WWE West
would want to zone my youtube channel
there's a chance that I'm going to let
it out and I don't need to be the guy
that's doing that but for maybe older
kickers in the past
Gary Anderson Morten Andersen they
weren't able to kick balls further than
40 yards 45 yards
Venna Perry was still hitting 60 yard
field was 55 yard field goals and his
knee was obviously lingering all the way
from training camp he had to take some
time off so if I'm Adam Vinatieri I've
accomplished everything in life I have
Super Bowls I have the points record
I'm very well beloved by every person
that's ever played football with him and
in his mind the most competitive mind I
think he thinks he still has some time
it's just gonna have to come back - how
was rehab goes how the surgery goes
which i think is happening tomorrow and
i don't think we've seen the last but I
think there is a much better chance than
most people think to see him kick a ball
again I just I just think we have to see
how the rehab plays because he's an
old-ass man I mean let's just be honest
he's an old man at this point in the NFL
yeah
last one for you Pat I've never said
this to you before and I've known you
for jeez almost 10 years I think at
least
tell me about you and the cheese at bowl
that's a great great statement you just
said Jana the cheese at Bowl Rich Eisen
is the biggest best bowl of all time
not because last year people called it
the most absurd and most satisfying Bowl
they've ever watched but because this
year in Arizona on December 27th two
days after a birthday a little bit after
Hanukkah and there will be a bowl game
between Mike reaches Wazzu Cougars and
the Air Force Falcons and I will be
sitting atop a 2-story cheez-it box
right on the side of the field in people
from all across the globe can be sitting
in that box with me let you know how how
well they got a tweet out the hashtag
cheese pick me Pat entry and that's
cheese as in cheese it CHD easy pick me
Pat entry showcasing their love of Jesus
just as much as I do in the rest of the
world just with a photo or a video the
ones who love cheese it's the most woman
a chance to sit alongside me 20 things
in the air field side energy ziplocs
free hotel free airfare best day of your
life watching the best ballgame to ever
exist with your friends at Jesus so
sitting it's a a it's it's a
monster-sized cheese at box now or do
you sit your legs dangling over the box
or their seats on top I mean is there a
railing what else is up there Pat I mean
give me a little bit more or are we
still working on is that still being
workshopped just for the sake of this
conversation yes um let's assume that
the cheese of folks not only the best
snack to ever exist
but also civilized humans so let's
assume that we're putting our feet on a
dirty floor with a little bit of a
boundary so we don't fall off yep all
we're gonna have is a bird's eye view a
perfect view best seat in the house for
the best ball game of all time but to be
completely candid I have not seen it I
have no idea
and then just again if you're sharing
the same cheese at Bowl don't go bowling
with levy on bail before sitting up
there with you and sticking their mitts
into that bowl right back you know I'm
saying rich Oh rich I saw what you did
there and that is why it's cold full sir
it's called buttoning up right no I mean
yeah by the way pin on it early too we
circled back to it we put out your
buttoning it up with a flu joke put a
pin in it pulled it out and then came
right back around that's exactly what I
did Pat you know but again I also
appreciate how you dropped every
platform that you have you even mention
your Twitter Instagram at Pat McAfee
show you gave us you gave us your a-game
you gave us some information and you
just gave you just gave us yourself Pat
that's who you are and I appreciate it
you know that together if we did a show
together I think there's no stopping us
quite honestly you know yes I guess
there was a chance where I was gonna
make an appearance on that NFL hundred
old-time team okay I sent not that on
the team but in that show okay you Chris
mr. Belichick potentially filming Zach
Taylor over there incredible job
I look forward to that every single week
it's nice to make a little trip back in
the history of football and I think you
do a fantastic job yeah I mean you lost
your spot to Ray guy and Shane LeClair
do you like those choices as partners do
you think those were going to say Mike
was the greatest of all time he's a guy
who anytime you played against him you
would leave beer for the opposing team
specialist he's a man's man yeah and he
could kick the hell out of it at
football I'm very lucky to call Shane
luckily a friend and right guy I mean he
was revolutionary he was a trailblazer
but he wouldn't be able to hold the jock
of most NFL butters today Wow
that's the hottest thing you did we'll
even hear back come on now really he
couldn't I mean it's just like it's
every sport you know once somebody
figures he was revolutionary Trailblazer
could do a lot of great things with the
football but after those practices and
techniques get honed in and exercises
and everything like that I mean he just
has no chance what way guy be able to
dominate this year if he grew up in this
era I think so you lookin great athlete
but for me his his film and stuff like
that his numbers aren't like oh this
guy's great it but he didn't really
stand a chance because he was setting
the tone for everybody to follow him in
my eyes Shane like what about arguing
you're not destroying the brand here
I mean this is Brandon Brandon sit
sounds like to me well I could be pretty
biased too because I should have won the
right guy award me picked somebody else
that he's friendly I didn't for the
college football award show I might rent
a suit my dad had to take days off for
work for us to go down this stupid
Awards Show and out of the three that he
picked we weren't the right three to be
the finalist other people are much
better than us three three finalist I
was clearly the best thought I was going
to get an award was ready to burn it
down with a good acceptance speech
instead of a guy picked a kid he was
friends with the coach up and I'll hate
him forever for that I think you did
really good things for the punting brand
and I just think shame lack words the
best you rented a suit I'm sorry I
wouldn't let you go but you rented a
suit for that you rented well the
college kid and I played punter and
kicker I wasn't getting hundred-dollar
Handy's you know West Virginia just I
had to rent a suit I went down there huh
huh it rained I didn't even get to go to
Disney World the whole thing was just a
bad bad memory and Ray guy's face is the
face of that whole entire memories with
me no man it's you if you had only
invited him to your team-building
function Pat maybe this whole thing
would have been different you know you
know I think Ray guy would have crushed
it team camaraderie building barbecue
but he wasn't invited so to hell with
them and shout-out to both of them for
making it and I'm very happy for Ray guy
getting all of him
it's good for punters going forward but
you the man hashtag cheese pick pick me
Pat entry and tag at cheese it on
Twitter for your chance to sit next to
Pat atop a very large cheese at box at
the cheese at Bowl I get that right I
know what that's Pat McAfee everybody at
Pat McAfee show on Twitter Instagram for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app